researchers witnessed a spectacular
fiery underwater volcano explosion and
captured it on video it's believed to be
the deepest ocean volcano eruption ever
recorded the undersea Pacific Ocean
explosions in May of this year were
recorded using a remote operating
vehicle under the tone of the vehicle
motors recorded by a hydrophone you can
hear the muffled sounds of the
explosions still audible under 4,000
feet of ocean water an expedition team
which included researchers from the
University of Washington and the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration was conducting
observations in an area of the Pacific
bounded by the island nations of Samoa
Tonga and Fiji the eruption was
southeast of Samoa one of the lead
scientists called it an underwater
fourth of July images show large molten
lava bubbles about three feet across
glowing red vents ejecting lava into the
sea and lava flows across the seafloor
this west Motta volcano stands more than
a mile high off the ocean floor its
eruptive area is about the length of a
football field it is producing Bonin
night lavas believed to be among the
hottest erupting on earth in modern
times researchers believe they have a
unique chance to study magma formation
and how the earth recycles material
where tectonic plates slide against each
other a microbiologist on the team found
diverse microbes in the extreme
conditions and they observed a small
species of shrimp thriving it's believed
to be the same shrimp species found at
erupt of sights more than 3,000 miles
away mission scientists believe 80% of
eruptive activity on earth occurs in the
ocean and most volcanoes are in the deep
sea but in
till this discovery NOAA and the
National Science Foundation had
sponsored submarine volcano research for
25 years without observing a deep ocean
eruption like this one which is now
recorded for all of us to see